Pittsburgh under pressure here from Carolina
it's Burns across for slaven his shot def Flex
wide terraine and back on Golden delich a sneaky
good save early well the Toronto Maple Leaf pass
comes back to Chatfield he'll find bunting
again steers himself right into the check of
Pon goes cross I to orav in the slot kakami Rob
by n delovic has been out of this world insane
at making big saves and that's Point Blank cck
down by Jake gensel feeds Crosby back over the
line for gimel he connects to Rael backhander
off the post K kov got a piece L tag gips rips
sa mayo and he was so close still scoreless
that was just some simple spinner drop pass
real simple speaking of we got Swaggy P on
our pregame show you saw him with Haley in
the building tonight first intermission cby
def Flex it in talk about sick how about
Sid finishes his check in the corner when you're
man on man Josh we get a great look at it right
there finishes check in the corner and then
execution jumping past his man to the net that's
Brady Shay in the corner let's get a great look at
him here makes a play but he's on the right side
of him then quick execution great read by gensel
take away the wall and it's a bang bang last game
he moved into 13th alltime sole possession as a
charie moves in around orloff no AAR on goal save
coov he in on the ice penalty I believe we'll get
a look at the saari chance though just out muscles
out battles and look at that the Poke check
we see coov he does this he's done it in the
shootout there's our Super Mole presented
by Ahn I think it was out of the icing he
was trying to figure out who was on the out
there yeah he didn't look too happy with it
the way he was pointing around Burns a
drive off the Draw N delovic guess what
army the glove again says hello then hot
delovic try to take care of it himself he
lost possession a drive from slave def Flex
wide adventurous start to this UPMC power
play butuk knocked down Graves after the puck
around the wall kept in by pesi with AER and a
save made by NAD delovic Penguins do have six
Power Play Goals over the last four games to
your point Army as the kanes come in short-handed
stall rumbles to the net and delovic a great stop
head back in 15 seconds on the power play Jeff
Carter trigger man and a save made ketov they
dig for it it's frozen great chance here as they
finally get it in and get it set up pretty good
and Carter just able to walk in off that flank
that patented Jeff Carter snaper shot that on
may have something here his wrist shot the flex
wide aari jams it that's blocked rebound stop by
kov and he gets another opportunity from o Conor
can't get it to go by there's no l again right
at the net drewel Conor sniffing as well as you
mentioned earlier Army so these power plays they
become even more magnified third opportunity here
for the Penguins they have three shots on their
first two and Sid talked about it this morning
here's a chance for Crosby his shot stopped by
ketov mother that play but that power play and
Crosby on that flank taken by Pon turns it over
to bunting in come Carolina it's cocky for Michael
bunting down low wraps it around turns it out and
a save made by n delovic right back to Shay
he'll rip that's blocked bunting fans on the
shot and a pence survive that one as they clear
to Center who's can IND DS it deep oh good thing
he whiffed on that it looked like movich picked
that chance up late for bunting off a shin pad L
on his tape maybe spinning a bit off that Shin
pad right they dodged the bullet there back in
comes Carolina it's NIS for buting Second Chance
backhander save rebound off the crossbar NES with
a great look for couldn't finish delovic loses
his stick on this save this attempt scrambling
to get across he throws everything he can over
there did he get a piece of that oh no not rap
penguins survive a hard shift and I they got
still some tired guys out there slaven shot to
flex through everyone here's Drury to the slot
Jack Drury passing for terbine and in front
pinballs in and a bad bounce there for the pens
a great bounce for Carolina and theyve tied it at
one Tavo tabin and put the puck on goal everyone
else was almost at a minute and a half and this
was just an unlucky play but that face off so
big they get the face off off the icing getting
the penguin stuck on the ice tired it just hits
n delovic hits Lank skate and it gets in behind
him off a pass bouncing towards the line kept
in by Carolina Mason lost the handle charging
ahead is Harkins he's pass Mason Harkins shot say
could check up rebound it didn't let it go how
did that stay out the check off gets a piece him
just blasting through this check one shot tough
angle oh just that fit win the most recent one in
November was the first that was not by only a goal
a 4-2 Victory otherwise been all one goal games
here's the same situation zor rumbles in safe
ketov and he covers the rebound Zone disrupted he
just kind of reached back and pulled it straight
out in front of him and kept going and tried
to beat him across wide to that post using his
reach great effort by zahna fighting off
Defenders using his body bunting back the
other way for Carolina down low NES looking
for help bof shot off the post comes back to
kckm it'll rotate around for Rael down
low gensel lets it go to Crosby lowers
the shoulder backhander blocked rebound the
cheet got a piece and then the second attempt
was stopped in the blue painton clear looking
him getting low right under Brent Burns he's
trying to get the stick a big guy he just
kind of squirel his way underneath him no
one's better Malin couldn't handle the
pass takes it back 3 seconds left in OT
Malin will open up fire save made Crosby Deni
on the rebound Crosby back to Malin Carlson
what timer blocked rebound it's loose and the
Pence can't put it in 20 seconds to go here's
Carlson back to Malin shot is blocked one timer
off the crossbar from Crosby are you kidding
megh come on get on it's 15 for 33 in his career
Rael can't tuck it in ketov squeezes the
Pats together flat right across that dot
line right to the hash marks Stephen n firmly
entrenched in Carolina now 0 for one in his
career in the shootout here's n Save n delovic
righty shot on that angle and just did a half
Clapper and tried to go Sydney Crosby 43 of 110
his career in the shootout here he comes Crosby
score
just came in measuring quick
hands and then it's gone see you
Lan the check stopped him couldn't
elevate it enough usually pretty good
it just kind of popped on a stick
there terrain to keep it alive for
Carolina M doich says no and the
Penguins win it in the shootout
out